ja es geht um um das Heizen an sich und
da damit ist am Ende jeder Bundesbürger
oder jeder Bürger auch in diesem Land
betroffen Robert Habeck möchte ab
kommendem Jahr das Öl und Gasheizungen
nicht mehr neu eingebaut werden dürfen
und dann soll es einen schrittweises
Verbot geben bis endgültig 2045 keine
einzige Öl und Gasheizung in diesem Land
mehr am Netz ist und für Wärme sorgen
kann das eine riesen Problem und zwar
aus verschiedenen Gründen es gibt zum
einen gar nicht genug Alternativen wenn
man mit den Verbänden spricht
beispielsweise den
wärmepumpenherstellern oder Herstellern
anderer alternative Heizungsart dann
sagen die wir werden das gar nicht
schaffen es gibt 8 Millionen das
Etagenheizungen beispielsweise in
Deutschland und es gibt doch keine
richtige Technik wie die eigentlich
ausgetauscht werden sollen es fehlt
Anleitung denn wenn man nicht mit Gas
und Öl heizen kann ja mit was dann
beispielsweise mit Wärmepumpen die große
Frage gibt es davon dann in kurzer Zeit
genügend oder mit Fernwärme aber wir
wissen dass die Prozesse
Fernwärmeleitung zulegen
wahnsinnig lang sind und langwierig das
heißt auch da gibt es ein Problem
fehlende Leitung das gleiche gilt für
die Stromnetze denn Wärmepumpen werden
ja mit Strom betrieben und was vor allem
fehlt und das ist ganz ganz wichtig das
sind Fachkräfte das sind Handwerker das
sind beispielsweise Estrichleger das
sind Installateure das sind diejenigen
auch die die Wärmepumpen Einbauen von
daher ist das und das ist jetzt nicht
nur meine Meinung sondern auch die viele
Experten was Robert Habeck dort plant
absolute
Utopie und es wird höchste Zeit das
Robert habe als Traumtänzer von seinem
Seil ohne Netz und doppelten Boden
hinuntersteigt und endlich realistische
Politik macht realistische Politik das
wäre schön du sagst aber auch selbst
sollte das nicht utopisch sein es ist
auch ökologisch gar nicht unbedingt
sinnvoll ist das richtig dieser Plan ich
glaube das ist gut ist wenn man dafür
sorgt dass weniger fossile Brennstoffe
überhaupt genutzt werden um weniger CO2
in die Luft zu Pulver vollkommen richtig
aber am Ende ist auch immer die Frage
die müssen wir uns immer Stellen ist das
was geplant wird speziell auch hier in
Deutschland ist das eigentlich der
weisheitsletzter Schluss ist der Euro
den wir für zusätzlichen Klimaschutz
einsetzen bei uns eigentlich wirklich am
besten aufgehoben oder ist es nicht so
wenn man Klimaschutz auch als globales
Problem und Aufgabe sieht nicht viel
besser diesen Euro ganz woanders
einzusetzen weil er dort für den
Klimaschutz ein viel größerer Nutzer wir
müssen immer sehen unsere Häuser sind
schon in der Regel extrem gut gedämmt es
gibt die Dreifachverglasung wann hat man
überlegt macht man vierfach Verglasung
das wäre so viel mehr teurer obwohl der
nutzen so viel geringer ist dass man
einfach schauen muss und das muss diese
Bundesregierung muss auch Robert habe
begreifen ist es wirklich sinnvoll das
letzte Mühe an Energie sparen und
emissionsverzicht in Deutschland
rauszupressen oder sollte man lieber den
1 € nehmen und ihm beispielsweise in
China einsetzen um dort den Neubau von
weiteren Kohlekraftwerken zu verhindern
das könnte für das Weltklima an sich wie
viel effektiver sein völlig klar ist auf
jeden Fall ich glaube Wärmepumpe würde
so oft gegoogelt wie noch nie seit
gestern
Wärmepumpe zu Hause
genau aber das ist ja genau das Problem
was ich ansprechen wenn ich jetzt im
Blick immer zu Landwirtschaft nehme wir
haben die schärfsten Gesetze bundesweit
ich denke nur ans Glyphosat Verbot wir
arbeiten da hin dass die das ja der
Wunsch den man zumindestens von einigen
mitbekommen dass wir ökologischer werden
gewohnt dass jeder wieder ein Schwein
und eine Kuh zu Hause hat und zwei
Hühner die Eier legen und sich dann alle
selbst versorgen dass er so der Wunsch
von allen aber vollkommen Utopie wir
brauchen doch und wir wollen doch eigene
Lebensmittel hier produzieren wo wir
wissen wie sie produziert werden die
auch den reichen für unsere Versorgung
auch und was wir jetzt machen und was
passiert ist eben das Problem dass wir
die Landwirtschaft da auch hingehen
verkleinern die Kommentare Landschaft
abdrehen und dann Produkte kaufen aus
dem Ausland wo kann ich wissen was was
drin ist und wir haben hier die höchsten
Standards das ist ja ähnlich jetzt was
fordert bei dem Thema Klima aber wir
nutzt das dann nachher uns glaube ich
hier in Deutschland gar nicht und da
muss man wirklich den Blick fürs reale
haben und Realpolitik machen Frau stolze
siehe als Biologin die Grünen liefern
natürlich aber auch irgendwie das ab was
sie angekündigt haben Klimaschutz ist
das oberste Ziel und danach handeln wir
auch man kriegt also das was man gewählt
hat ja also ich persönlich habe die
Grünen nicht gesehen
aber sag mal natürlich ist Klimaschutz
ein Heeres Ziel aber ich glaube es ist
fatal wenn man dabei völlig blauäugig
vorgeht und auch kurzsichtig vorgeht und
genau den Eindruck habe ich bei dieser
Regierung und auch wie sie gerade sagten
ich glaube man muss überlegen welchen
Anteil sozusagen an klimaschädlichen
CO2-Ausstoß hat in Deutschland überhaupt
und da sieht man dass es ein ganz
geringer Prozentsatz dessen ist was
weltweit passiert das heißt wenn wir
hier auf Teufel komm raus rumschrauben
an unserer an unserem Energie verbraucht
dann wird es der Welt insgesamt gar
nicht so sehr viel nutzen wir kann uns
aber selber massiv und es ist auch sagen
wir mal blauäugig insofern als man ja
darauf setzt jetzt bei Wärmepumpen zum
Beispiel das alles sozusagen vom Strom
letztlich nachher abhängig ist dann auch
E-Fahrzeuge und so weiter das heißt
jetzt wird schon drüber nachgedacht dass
der Strom dann rationiert werden muss
muss weil es gar nicht möglich ist alle
gleichzeitig ständig mit unbegrenzten
unbegrenzten Mengen Strom zu versorgen
das heißt es ist es ist sowas von von
jenseits der Realität dass man wirklich
Angst bekommen muss bei dieser Regierung
dann muss Angst bekommen sie geben wir
unser Spiel gleich äh Tipps für ein
glücklich in das Leben gehört für ihr
glückliches lebende Wärmepumpe dazu
haben sie schon eins nein aber man merkt
wir haben in Deutschland echten
Fachkräftemangel und vor allem in der
Politik das heißt also die dieser
Irrsinn solche Ideen rauszuhauen und
nicht zu wissen wie das umgesetzt wird
das erinnert mich an die Situation wo
habe ich über das Thema Insolvenz
geplappert hat und wo man einfach merkt
da fehlen die Grundkenntnisse und das
ist etwas was mir dann wo ich dann
nachvollziehen kann dass viele Menschen
die sich ohnmächtig fühlen auch wirklich
ein schlechtes Gefühl bekommen weil
teilweise so ja nicht vorhersehbar und
hochgradig irrationale Entscheidung
getroffen werden und man einfach nicht
weiß dem das wird das verunsichert
Menschen und Unsicherheit
lädt in der Psychologie am negativsten
das heißt du kannst mit Schwierigkeiten
besser umgehen als mit Unsicherheit und
das was wir im Moment erleben ist eine
Politik die die Menschen verunsichert
und deshalb leiden immer mehr da drunter
unter den gesellschaftlichen Bedingungen
und immer weniger sind da dies auffangen
ich glaube das was Frau stolze gerade
gesagt hat muss man sich wirklich noch
mal auf der Zunge zergehen lassen dass
wir es hier mit einem
Bundeswirtschaftsminister wichtig das
Wort Wirtschaft zu tun haben viertgrößte
Industrienation der Welt des Deutschland
immer noch der eine Politik betreibt bei
der er selbst bzw auch sein Behördenchef
Klaus Müller Chef der Netzagentur jetzt
angekündigt hat dass es ab nächsten Jahr
dann bei Überlastung des Netzes zu Strom
nationierungen kommen kann sei es bei
E-Autos oder beispielsweise bei Heizung
also Wärmepumpenheizung es muss man sich
vorstellen wir sind also auf dem Weg
nicht zu sagen wir erweitern das
Stromangebot und jeder kann also tun und
machen was er will und sind offen für
Firmen die nach Deutschland kommen weil
sie hier besonders günstig Energie
bekommen und auch einige Partei total
sicher sondern das Gegenteil passiert
ein Wirtschaftsminister sagt gibt offen
zu sein Behördenchef wir werden zu Strom
Rationierungen kommen da fällt mir
ehrlicherweise gar nicht mehr viel an
der müsste man eigentlich sagen da hat
der Wirtschaftsminister sein kernziel
eine florierende Wirtschaft zu erhalten
bzw noch mehr zum Wachstum einer
Wirtschaft beizutragen komplett verfehlt
und in der Schule würde man mutmaßlich
sagen das ist eine Sechs und das ist
einfach ein Thema
sozusagen aber man fragt sich in dem
Zusammenhang wo bleibt denn jetzt eine
starke SPD wo bleibt eigentlich das
absolut FDP hat auch angekündigt ihr
konnten dickes Veto von uns man fragt
sich aber wird das gehört oder ziehen
die das Ding jetzt durch es gibt ein
Koalitionsvertrag in dem steht ja drin
dass man beim Thema
erneuerbare Energien und beim Thema
schadstoffarmes heizen vorankommen will
da steht jetzt nicht explizit drin dass
es ein Öl und gasheizungsverbot geben
soll aber es gibt einen gab einen
Koalitionsausschuss im vergangenen Jahr
da wurden Dinge noch mal festgezogen
auch diese sogenannten 65%
erneuerbare energienanteil an dem dem
der also an der Heizung an dem
heizungsausstoß oder der Wärmeproduktion
von daher gibt es für die FDP im relativ
wenig Möglichkeiten da jetzt noch mal
auszubrechen wenn man nicht koalitions
untreu werden möchte und die Signale die
wir kriegen sind auch ehrlicherweise
nicht so dass die FDP sagt wir stellen
uns auf die Hinterbeine und das ganze
wird so nicht kommen da geht's eher um
nirgend aber man hat sich auf diesen
Koalitionsvertrag geeinigt Klimaschutz
ist gut aber Klimaschutz muss wie sie
auch gesagt haben so gemacht werden dass
er klappt und Klimaschutz darf nicht
dazu führen dass dieses Land das
eigentlich noch ein sehr reiches Land
ist dann auf dem Abstieg ist denn dann
können wir uns Klimaschutz mit
Sicherheit gar nicht mehr leisten für
mich kommen da ehrlich gesagt auch noch
zwei andere Aspekte mit ins Spiel und
das eine ist Hybris und das andere ist
Heuchelei die Hybris stecken mich darin
dass Deutschland hier auftreten will als
Vorbild also das Motto am deutschen
Wesen soll die Welt genesen kennen wir
aus unerfreulicher Geschichte diese
Haltung die finde ich höchst gefährlich
und die Heuchelei besteht darin dass man
dann sozusagen auch das Risiko eingeht
dass man das Problem ins Ausland
verlagert das heißt dass wir an Teil
unseres Strombedarfs decken mit dem
Strom von Atomkraftwerken die dann
woanders stehen das heißt wir heucheln
sozusagen Reinheit wer räucheln Ökologie
und in Wirklichkeit überlassen wir
sozusagen die Stromproduktion dann
Ländern wie schw Eden wie Frankreich wie
Polen und so weiter und als hätten wir
dann dadurch eine reine Weste und das
ist aber so offensichtlich dass ich mich
wundere dass man sich über überhaupt in
der Politik so zu agieren wurden sie
abgezockt oder reingelegt
das ist also eine Verzehnfachung jetzt
melden unsere Reporter kümmern sich um
Ihren Fall
für Sie